la parade des déesses à paris de l'arc
de triomphe à la tour eiffel plus de
1500 de ses voitures qui avait fait
sensation il ya 50 ans lors de leur
présentation au salon de l'automobile
depuis un million et demi d'exemplaires
ont été vendus en france et à l'étranger
la ds citroën à l'image d'une époque
pour ces collectionneurs passionnés
nicolas le marine et jean moulin
le réveil est difficile les 8 heures du
matin mais pas question de rater les
défilés 1600 ds à la queue leu leu
rassemblés dans paris ds à fourrure pour
l'hiver ds cabriolet pour l'été bref des
modèles pour tous les goûts et de toutes
les couleurs
au volant de sa décapotable dominique de
richter lui boit du petit lait
pour moi ce rassemblement c'est presque
un des plus beaux jours que je vis parce
que j'en ai jamais eu autant de ds et
pour moi on vient tous les modèles
toutes les couleurs tous les intérieurs
possible le trésor de ce collectionneur
se cache derrière une porte de garage
4ds des voitures extrêmement rare qui
n'existe plus qu'à quelques exemplaires
chacune
comme par exemple ce coupé chapron c'est
disons un peu long le graal dans la ds
parce que c'est le il y en a eu neuf il
en reste 3 des véhicules modifiés comme
cette déesse concorde transformé pour
que les chefs d'entreprise puis s'y
asseoir sans enlever leur chapeau et
puis donc il y à la ds cabriolet
idéal pour une petite croisière c'est
pas une voiture qui sportive sais pas
s'il ya une apparence un peu de bateaux
on à vide
en 50 ans la ds a connu des hauts et des
bas et même si elle a tourné de l'oeil
en 1975 pour ses fans elle tient
toujours la route